hello everyone and welcome to our quiz
today on microsoft excel we would
request you to bear with us for a few
minutes for other people to join this
stream
feel free to introduce yourself in the
comments section while we wait for a few
more people
just as a reminder to take part in the
quiz it is highly recommended to use
your mobile phone to visit the website
www.venti.com
and use the code 2303 5639 to take part
in the quiz
you can see the code on the screen it's
mentioned at the top
it's visible on the screen you can also
use a different tab on your laptop
browser to take part in the quiz but a
live stream will be broadcasting the
results as soon as the people give the
answers so it is beneficial to have both
screens right in front of you so you can
be aware of how the standings are going
to be
once you open the link and input the
code just wait for the quest to start
and be ready to answer the questions
right away the quicker you answer the
more points you get so think fast and
click faster
but before we get started with our quiz
let's take a look at the basics of
microsoft excel with a small
introduction to the topic
so
what exactly is microsoft excel
so microsoft excel is a software product
designed and developed by microsoft for
storing data in an organized way that is
rows and columns
it is capable of manipulating data based
on the mathematical operations
followed by that microsoft excel is also
used to extract the insights from the
data and represent it in the form of
visually appealing graphs and charts
now that we have a basic understanding
or an overview per se of what is
microsoft excel
let's learn a bit about its fundamentals
in our next topic
when it comes to the fundamentals of
microsoft excel we need to know to
install microsoft office
when you install microsoft office on
your computer you will have various
microsoft products powerpoint word excel
visio onedrive etc so one of which is
microsoft excel used to handle sheets
so when you get started with microsoft
excel first time this is what you will
see this is the first page
which is particularly called as the
microsoft excel home page where you will
have a different type of sheets
microsoft excel will give you
suggestions based on the type of sheet
you want to work with as well
so once you get started with the type of
sheet that you require you can start
your work
this particular option is called the
toolbar menu you will have the file home
insert drawer page layout formulas data
review view help and other topics so
this is the tools that you will be using
to work on your data by using microsoft
excel
furthermore we have a toolbar ribbon
so you can see some of the options like
file home insert draw page layout etc
for example we have selected the home
toolbar ribbon here
which has its own set of operations so
when i press on the home total driven it
gives the different kind of operations
that can be performed
in a further more detailed way though we
have toolbar groups
like we saw in the last slide a
particular
ribbon is segmented into groups you can
see the first group as paste copy format
printer etc etc
the second group is the font size of the
font to increase the size of the font
degrees bold italic all those text
formatting skills that are not present
by default
and the last one you can see the text
alignment as well which is the very next
one of the text formatting section so
each and every group has the separate
functions and each and every set is
known as a group
you can also see a different arrow small
arrow on the corner of the font
see this arrow is used in toolbar group
so the group is not able to fill all the
operations or the functionalities in one
single provided section so when you
click on this particular arrow mark you
will have another dialog box open up
which introduces a different set of
operations that are not able to fit
now moving forward we have another topic
which are the cells and addresses
when you open a microsoft excel sheet
you can find different different boxes
each and every box is named as a cell
and each cell has its own address
for example the highlighted cell in the
image that you can see on the stream is
b3 the b is the column name and three is
the room name that's how you can map the
cells to the relative addresses in
microsoft excel
and apart from that you can have the
sheet tracker in the bottom left corner
of the excel sheet where you can
navigate through different sheets in the
same file itself
finally in the bottom right corner we
have the shade size adjuster where you
have an option of increasing or
decreasing the sheet size
so these are some of the basic
fundamentals of microsoft excel that you
need to keep in mind before we start the
quest
i would like to remind you again
that this is how or this is all you need
to know about microsoft excel from a
layman's perspective
to remind you to join the quiz visit the
website www.menti.com
and use the code that is being shown on
the screen which is 2303 5639 to give
your answer
like i mentioned before do try to join
the case using your mobile phone to keep
your eyes on the results of the quiz as
it progresses on this live stream this
will help you stay in touch with the
standings since the property winners
will be receiving amazon vouchers on
behalf of simply learn
faster answers equal higher points so
fire away as soon as you get aha
let's wait for a few minutes for more
people to join the quiz and then we can
get started
uh reminder guys
answers given in the youtube comments
cannot be considered as answers to the
questions and will not be considered for
vouchers so if you have the option
please go to the website and join the
quiz directly using the code mentioned
on the screen
wait for a few more people to join the
link using that code
any of you guys have any doubts
regarding ms excel that you need to get
cleared out you can just
ask those questions straight away in the
youtube comments screen
you already have experts sitting there
to answer your questions for you it can
be anything regarding to excel that you
have a download or you want to know any
question that we have in the quiz in
more detail please feel free to ask your
questions in the chat screen
just a few more moments
i must have enough people to start just
take a minute at max
okay so let's get started we have enough
people now so let's get started with our
first question of microsoft excel quiz
remember guys faster answers more points
don't miss out on the amazon vouchers
the first question is
in which year was microsoft excel first
released
is it option a 1995
is it option b 1985
is it c 1986 or d 1981
a reminder this question is not which
here was microsoft windows
first is the question is which here was
microsoft excel as a product first
released
five more seconds to give the answers
and the time is up
pretty split opinions uh the correct
answer is option b which is 1985.
uh back in the day charles simony which
is an early microsoft employee and the
man behind the creation of the
spreadsheets tool for microsoft
developed and deployed ms excel in 1985.
who would have ever known that a simple
spreadsheet application would become
such a revolution in data analytics one
day
anyway the first one was pretty simple
and knowledgeable simultaneously
let's see the leaderboard on how many
people were able to get the answer
correctly
uh considering list six people were able
to answer let's see those people at the
top but there'll be plenty of
opportunities for others to take the
position let's move on to question
number two
what is the shortcut key for flash fill
in
excel four options are either control
shift f
the second one is alt a
third option is control e for the fourth
option is shift f
what is the keyboard shortcut for flash
fill in microsoft excel
i assume this is a tool that many people
will be using in the daily work life so
i'm hoping a high number of correct
answers for this one
the most seconds
and the time is up
ah it's pretty fifty-fifth here the
correct option being
control e which is a third option
the flash fill is one of the latest
features
introduced to us with the microsoft
office 2013 version and above
it can be depicted as a pattern matching
feature that comes with excel in bed
it is so smart that it recognizes the
pattern your data is following and tries
to replicate it the way you wish it
would
for example let us imagine you have a
column with names and the names combined
with first middle and last names
if you want to separate the data in a
column title as full name into three
different columns that is the first
middle and last then microsoft excel's
flash fill would do it for you in a
fraction of a second for the entire
spreadsheet this is something that can
replace manual labor drastically
to know more go through the excel flash
fill tutorial on assembly lines youtube
channel to learn about it in more detail
10 people answered correctly so okay 9
from the top 10 negative word were able
to which will be pushing shivani down to
the 10th position and others to the top
remember guys faster answer more points
let's
put that to use in question number three
select the odd sum function out of the
given sum function
the options are the first option b sum
of a1 to a5
second one is a1 plus a2 up to a5 third
one is sum of a1 comma f5
and fourth option is sum of a1 e2 e3 e4
a5
which is the odd sum function out of the
given scope
time is almost up
three people answered correctly another
constraint was short in the time but all
the options seem correct
yet finish people got it right
so the sum aggregate function can be
used in multiple forms the first option
is where we provide the range of cells
from a1 to a5 the colon symbol is used
for range declaration the second option
is a brute force way of adding values in
cell addresses of a1 a2 e3 e4 and a5 the
fourth one is where we call the sum
function and past five parameters
directly with the individual cell
addresses separated by a comma
now clear by the third option was the
odd one out all the other options tried
adding five individual elements and the
third one was just adding two
so let's see what's the state of the
leaderboard right now
considering only three people answered
correctly
all three of them are part of the top 10
board
which pushes
prince to the top position let's even
keep his position consistent till the
end of the quiz
question number four
which of the following will prevent
users from writing irrelevant data on a
spreadsheet
is it a workbook protection
is it b data validation
is it c spreadsheet protection or the
conditional formatting
it's a very close
uh there's very very close
options that we have so make sure to
read the question correctly and the
options carefully which of the following
will prevent users from writing
irrelevant data in a spreadsheet
time is up
with majority giving the answer
correctly which is option b data
validation but before we if i explain
why i launched it let us understand the
question
most of you have presumed the answer
would be either work with protection or
spreadsheet protection since we had the
term avoid the idea was to prevent users
from adding invalid or irrelevant data
not to prohibit them all together
coming to conditional formatting it is
just procedure employed more like self
formatting or number formatting with a
condition
so this brings us to data validation as
the last option data validation is
employed to avoid invalid data entries
by enabling suggestions errors and
warnings in the entire spreadsheet
first you suggest the user to write
relevant data or choose from the
available options
if the user tries to forcefully bypass
or overrule the suggestion and type in
an invalid data entry then the
spreadsheet will not allow it and will
throw an error
the error programming can be done only
with the help of data validation in ms
excel
for more details check out our data
validation in excel tutorial which
clearly explains everything in and
around data validation using microsoft
excel
only the bottom of the leaderboard was
able to answer that correctly which
might suggest a change in the
leaderboard and a lot of change in the
leaderboard with ola being the fastest
one to answer this question
let's move on to question number five
question number five states which of the
following sum functions is invalid
the four options being the first one is
sum
function second one is thumb if function
third option is some sq function and the
fourth one is sum if s function
each of the following sum function is
invalid
five more seconds 20 people have
answered already okay a lot of people
answered in the last second okay uh
how many
people already got it correct okay so
all the sum functions here relate to
some aggregation except first sum is p
sum sq is slightly different unlike the
other some functions the sum sq first
calculates the square of the given value
and adds the square of those given
values together
slightly different but enough to warrant
us or not answer to it
uh there seems to be three people left
out on the top 10 leaderboard which
pushes ola to the first person and
shashank to second guys are not a part
of the top 10 leaderboard please answer
fast so that you can get more points and
come up
let's move on to question number six
which asks how do you custom format
yourself in excel to make them invisible
you can see the four commands and the
four options
how do you custom format yourselves in
microsoft access to make them invisible
uh for anyone who joined on some youtube
stream uh well in the past few minutes
please go to the link www.menti.com
and use the code 2303 5639 to take part
in the quiz answers given in the youtube
chat section will not be considered for
amazon vouchers and which the top three
winners are going to get and nine people
were able to give the correct answer
this time which is the triple colon
symbol
the answer might feel a little of the
topic but if you dig a little deeper you
can understand that the overall question
is about formatting in excel
most of you have thought hiding or
deleting cells in excel would help but
they come under routine spreadsheet
practices
the last option of three semicolons the
semicolon commander custom self
formatting specially dedicated to hiding
your cells and data in them the
remaining special symbol options were
included to test whether viewers can
recognize the right custom formatting
option to turn it invisible the cells
will be present on the spreadsheet but
they will be invisible with customized
formatting they can be visible or
highlighted once you hover or click on
the cell
let's see if there is any drastic change
on the leaderboard
there might just be and there is hola
move from first position to the fourth
pushing prince sasha and gulu up to the
first second and third positions on the
leaderboard
quicker answers more points dale is
oldest time let's move on to question
number seven
question number seven asks which of the
following functions in excel works as a
trial and error approach
is it option a x lookup
is it option b v stat
is it see what if analysis or
the goal seek
which are the following question in
excel because our trial and error
approach
a lot of people answer this question in
the first
10 15 seconds let's see how many of them
are accurate i'm expecting a lot of
correct answers in this one
based on the frequency of how people
answer this
no
correct answer is option d which is goal
check the most we have thought what if
analysis is the right answer as can be
seen on the screen
in a way but not completely the idea of
including what if analysis option was to
confuse really the what-if analysis
combines goal seeks scenario manager and
data table methods
out of all of these goals is the process
that runs all the possible permutations
and combinations just like a trial and
error approach to find the right result
to fit the puzzle
on the other hand these stack and edge
stack functions are pretty recent
functions that will return the array
formed by appending each array argument
in a row and column fashion respectively
an x lookup is a new type of lookup
function that combines the ability of
hlookup and vlookup
under 10 people have answered this
question correctly which is odd but on
brand
depending on the question
shashank has only solidified his
position
further up top with the gap getting
bigger between the first and second
so others please answer fast while we
move to question number eight
what is the best tool to enter days of
the week for an entire year
is it option a cut and paste
is it option b flash fill
is it c find and replace
or option d data validation
which is the best tool to enter days of
the week for an entire year in a
spreadsheet
ten more seconds
a lot of the people did not answer this
one till now going to be a lot of last
entries for this one
there are a lot of last entries for this
one okay so time is up and
still majority we have the correct
answer which is flash fill
simple and direct question for those who
use accent daily really the cut and up
paste option could be the right answer
to an extent but it does not hold good
in a progressive state let us imagine
that you enter the next fiscal year the
approach does not seem feasible
similarly the find and replace option is
also not the right answer
or data validation sounds like the right
option to sum but again data validation
comes in a programming a spreadsheet to
accept the right and valid data
that leaves us flashfield
flashville comes in handy on multiple
occasions like understanding the pattern
splitting the existing data predicting
the successive data element based on the
existing data on the sheet
i hope some various subconscious mind is
still thinking about x lookup as it
sounded a little new
uh don't worry about it we have a
complete x lookup tutorial on our
channel so feel free to go through it
moving ahead let's see if there are any
rusty changes no
mostly similar
sandeep has moved up to second position
great going sandeep let's see if others
can catch up to him
but those who are already in the top 10
leaderboard
for every reason to answer questions
quickly the question number nine is
which symbols are used for denoting
absolute cell reference in microsoft
excel
let's see the four options
the exclamation mark dollar sign
ampersand symbol or simple hash
which of these symbols are used for
denoting absolute cell reference in
microsoft excel
almost everyone has answered this one
very quickly
three more seconds
okay the almost everyone got the answer
right which is the dollar symbol
for a moment we
could have selected the ampersand symbol
since ampersand is used as an address
symbol in popular programming languages
like c and all
let us discuss those possibilities in
these options
the exclamation mark means that the
workbook is a macro enabled workbook
with extension dot xlsm
the ampersand symbol is a calculation
operator that lets users join text items
without a function
the hash symbol is used to refer to a
spill range in microsoft excel
now we are left with the dollar symbol
exclusively used for cell references
when you try to denote absolute cell
references you need the dollar symbol to
do it in your formula but
everyone in the leaderboard was answer
able to answer the question correctly
and there's very little change in the
readable
let's move on to question number 10.
which of the following functions in
excel will help you count the number of
unique items in a given set
question is a mouthful so read it
carefully which of the following
functions in excel will help you count
the number of unique items in a given
set
is it option a unicode
is it be unique
is it c
unique
or the cubes.com
count the number of unique items in a
given set
majority gave the wrong answer which is
not unique the correct answer is keep
that count
the unica function will convert the
parameters passed into a unicode number
representing a character
the unique code function will give the
number for the first character of a
supplied text string
that leaves us with cubesatcom
the cubesatcount is a function in excel
that calculates the number of unique
items in a given set
that let's move on to the leaderboard
after which we can go to question number
11
okay only three people
answered correctly
which pushes mine to the second position
all right
let's go to question number 11 to see if
that leaderboard can be shaken up even
further
dash is used for task automation in
excel
often a macros is it option b power bi
is it c dashboard
or
the power query
which of these is used for task
automation in excel
10 more seconds
okay so time is up and
majority gave right but the answer is
being macros
see power bi is a business intelligence
tool that comes along with microsoft
excel that is specifically used for
analytics
a dashboard is a collection of charts
and graphs used to represent the
insights of the data interactively which
we already have put in the spreadsheet
power query is the tool that is used to
connect external data sources to excel
the last option left is macro
the macros in excel are executed in the
vba or the visual basics platform this
visual studio is exclusively designed
and deployed by microsoft and excel uses
it to design and deploy its macros
macros and excel are reprogrammed
functions that redundantly occur in the
analytics process they eliminate the
repeated usage of the formulae by
automating these processes so you do not
have to go through them again and again
when working throughout your spreadsheet
uh with anubhav has now moved to ninth
position from fifth because of his
inability to answer this one question
competition is fierce
so let's see how far the top three
players can hold their positions moving
on to question number 12
how can you compare the two columns in
excel
the first option being compare function
the second one is the exact function
the third one is unicare function
and the fourth is v lookup which of
these can you use to compare two columns
in ms xl
people answer very fast when it comes to
function related questions it feels
all right already most of the people
have answered in the with 10 seconds to
spread
okay so time is up
split by the thinnest of margins with 10
people giving the wrong answer the
correct answer here is the lookup
vlookup function in excel is a search by
comparison method that checks and
compares individual cells with the
search key elements and recognizes when
there is a match
similarly we have h lookup for row by
search and x lookup a combination of
hlookup and vlookup
the exact function is excel is used to
compare
but the catch is that it is designed to
simultaneously compare only two
different cells but the question was to
compare two different columns which are
only possible using vlookup
and lastly unica it returns a character
represented by unicode number 32 which
is a space character they already
covered the use of unica in a previous
question
three people answered out of the top 10
in this quiz
uh which does not introduce a lot of
change but it does
push gema to the eighth position
making a late push for the leaderboard
which moves us to question number 13.
which type of table in excel can
automatically adjust its size according
to the addition or deletion of elements
is the option a a variable table
is option b dynamic table is it c a
pivot table
or the dynamic pivot table
which of these tables can automatically
adjust your size
irrelevant of if you add or delete
products later on even after the data
has already been filled for the first
time
and the time is up
oh majority gave with answer pivot table
where the correct answer is dynamic
table
dynamic table adjust is size by itself
whenever a new data element is added to
it
the table can be converted to a dynamic
table by making use of offset functions
looking at the rest of the
options the term variable table was
added more to create little ambiguity
although only one person
fell to that trick the pivot table in
excel which majority went with is an
interactive data table it is used to
summarize the existing data but not
change itself altogether when a new
element is added so that does not make
it dynamic or makes it static to be more
precise
we might see a lot of shaker considering
only one of the top you have answered
and
mike is now moved to the first position
cutting the lead also by
a few points
let's move on to question number 14.
what is the shortcut key combination to
enable the quick analysis option to
insert instant charts in excel
this is a question that only uh
experienced excel users may be able to
answer
but have a go at
the option being a control queue
controlled as control chip lower arrow
key or option the ctrl shift upper arrow
key
each of these will enable the quick
analysis option
to insert
instant charts in an excel sheet
time is up
and
majority answered correctly which is
option e it's the control q
we all know the quickest uh quickest way
to transform tabular data into a chart
is by using the chart option available
in the insert menu but is there a
shortcut
anyone who uses these charts may have
come across a shortcut key combination
when the mouse pointer hovers over the
charts icon
excel displays the shortcut key
combination now the question was to find
the correct combination which is control
plus q
the last two options were to select
cells and the second option was to save
the workbook
like i said it's something that only the
season excel users may be able to grasp
which is apparently nine out of our top
ten answers for this quiz
very little change in the leaderboard so
we'll be moving on to question number 15
we are already more than halfway
so if you have not yet seen the side of
the leaderboard it's time to start
answering quickly now
question number 15 is how can you cycle
through all the combinations of absolute
and relative cell references in a
formula
the given options are control plus enter
shift plus f5
alt plus enter
or just plain f4
how we cycle to the combinations of
absolute and relative cell formulas
relative references in a formula object
five more seconds
okay times up and
got the correct answer for majority
which is f4 when you select a range of
cells to run through a mathematical or
logical formula you need to set them in
a range such that every iteration of the
formula can run through individual cells
one after the other
this is possible only when you declare
the absolute addresses this can be done
only with the help of function key f4
majority were able to answer correctly
which should not introduce a lot of
changes
barring one the top 10 leaderboard
pushing us to question number 60.
which shortcut is used to add a macro to
your spreadsheet
is it option a control q
it's at option b control plus f 11
is it c f i
or option d control plus s
we already covered macros in a previous
question where we went through the
the use and where these situations where
are there what are the situations where
we can use macros to our advantage
there's a shortcut for adding
micro-based stretching
three more seconds
and time this up
with the
correct answer being control plus f11 as
majority of the people were able to
detain so as discussed control queue is
a shortcut option to insert instant
charts into the spreadsheet
the fi function in excel is used to
access the go to options dialog box
control s is by default the data saving
shortcut key irrespective of excel
so that leaves us with control plus f5
which happens to be the shortcut for
adding macros to the excel spreadsheet
let me just find the answer by
eliminating the wrong options
and five people eliminated the others in
the top 10
which pushes sandeep
to the second position thanks to being
the fastest answer in the last question
see fastest answer will get your points
very quickly
so let's improve on that with question
number 17
which states which of the following
functions in excel will help you replace
the new text with the old text in
multiple instances
the first option is the place function
option b is the substitute function
option c is switch and option d is
choose you need to replace new text with
old text
very few questions left guys so let's
give out these answers very quickly if
you want to catch up to the top three in
the leaderboard
majority are third wrong which is the
correct option is substitute
the replace is obviously wrong see here
the replace and the substituted function
seem correct it can be confusing but
according to the question when you we
need to replace the text not in one but
multiple instances in one group
replace may work in ms word but in ms
excel replace will only work for one
instance
but the substitute will work for
multiple instances of the same
switch is a condition statement that
evaluates an expression against a list
of values to find the right result
switch function throws a default answer
if the right result is not found
the choose function selects an action
from a list of values based on the index
number
every option seemed to be a close match
but only
substitute was the correct answer
the top two were not able to answer
which might push shashank to the top
uh no does the shampoo's third position
with prince taking second spot and
pushing sandeep
all the way down to four which seems
like an insurmountable lead at this
point let's see if that can be supported
in the question number 18
it states how do you calculate the
difference between any two numbers in
microsoft excel
is the option a subtract function is it
option b the sum function
is it see the delta function or option 4
difference function
how can you calculate the difference
between any two numbers microsoft excel
which already gave the answer once again
some functions usually are
the questions regarding the functions
usually get very quick answer
time is up which means a lot of the
people were able to answer the question
no nobody was able to answer correctly
with the current option being option
four which is delta
see the two options are dedicatedly
added to test our viewers knowledge of
ms excel those are subtract and
both of these are non-existing functions
in excel
both the sum and delta functions can be
used to perform a subtraction operation
the sum function will carry subtraction
only if there is a negative number in
the set of values as can be understood
by this
word
but on the other hand the delta function
is dedicated to finding the difference
between the two given numbers
delta subtracts a smaller number from a
bigger number and prints the result
needless to say there is no change in
the leaderboard considering we did not
have anyone giving the right question
which decreases the number of questions
others get to close the gap to 6 where
question number 19 asks which function
will count all the cells having the data
stored in them
among the given options you can see a
sample spreadsheet on your screen where
you are answering the questions just
need to find the function to count the
total number of cells which have data
stored in them
is it option a count
is it option b count a
is it option b count if
or d count if s
times up
okay seven people pretty even approach
uh for the entire audience so the option
b is
current option which is count creep
each option added here is connected to
the count operation in one way or the
other according to the question we
should count the total number of cells
with the valid data
everything in the table is valid except
for a1 which is a blank cell now the
count function is used to count cells
only with numeric values and prints the
results at 30 which is the wrong answer
to print 43 as the right answer we need
to select the count a formula which
counts cells with data regardless of the
data type
countdyp and count fs are count
functions with logical conditions
leading to them
see
only one was able to answer question the
leaderboard
which
will push him up a second position
straight away see all it takes is one
question if you're in the top 10
leaderboard to really grab your spot
back
moving on to question number 20
how do you find the current date in
microsoft excel
it said option a the day function
is it optionally the today function
is it c workday function or d
workday dot intl
rather simple questions i am expecting a
lot of correct answers
in this one
but surprisingly not a lot of people
have answered yet which means a lot of
late entries again
okay the time is up now
which also is
majority answer correctly which is
today
uh the the day of function will
essentially help us find the weekday of
the calendar workday returns the nearest
work day to the given date value
and the intl function in microsoft
returns the date serial number before or
after a specified number of birthdays
with the custom weekend parameters
might see a shift in the leaderboard
this time around
we did sandeep has moved from fifth to
first in a matter of two questions okay
let's see if we can hold this position
we're going to the last five questions
of our quiz this time so
make use of them as much as you can
question number 21 states which of the
following is not a wildcard in microsoft
excel
is it option a the tilt symbol
is it b an exclamation mark
is it c
an asterisk or d question
which of the following is not a wild
card in microsoft excel
few more seconds left and we know the
right answer
okay time's up and three people the
least people answer the right option
which is the
exclamation mark
the
symbols with special meaning these
wildcards are used for very specific
purposes
the asterisk is used for text comparison
by taking the place of characters in an
existing text it can act as a
placeholder
the question mark wildcard is used for
getting an alternate suggestion of the
data in cells in a spreadsheet
real symbol is another wild card used as
a marker to indicate the next character
is little
and excel only have three wild cards so
the only odd man out was the
exclamation
no one answered in the top three
okay or in the top 10 for them
great so let's move on to question
number 22 four more questions to grab
your final spots
you forget to write the division
operator in the image below
what kind of error are you going to
encounter
you have the sample sheet with you
you just forget to write the division
operator
among the four options which is the name
value dip and null which are the errors
are you going to face because of the
upper condition
excuse me very slow answers this time
around
okay time is up and uh very few people
give the correct answer which is uh
microsoft excel has its own set of
errors and exceptions like any other
programming language each has a specific
meaning and points to a specific type of
error
since we have a division function on the
screen you might have thought it's div
i'm guessing which i can say clearly
where people answer div but it's not to
better understand this scenario let us
understand the meaning of individual
errors behind the options
the name error is shown when you end up
typing a method a function with a
special meaning
the value error is displayed when the
cell addresses is wrong or invalid
the div error is displayed when the
numerator or cell value is divided by
the number zero
and lastly our answer which is not is
displayed when the mathematical function
you entered is wrong
slightly tricky question
which will probably help
mine go to first position pushing
sandeep down to the second one
the very very thin margin okay last
three questions
till we receive our final spots for this
question
which mathematical function is smart and
gives result for only the visible sense
is it option is
subtotal
is it option b offset
is it option c sum
or option d indirect
which of them is smart and gives results
only visible sense
few more seconds
times up and we have the
okay
i will say majority answered correctly
but yeah a lot of people answered
correctly which is option a subtotal
see the correct answer is subtotal as
the the function is designed for a
column of data of vertical ranges it is
not designed for rows of data or
horizontal ranges
for example hiding a column does not
affect
the to
affect the subtotal when you subtotal a
horizontal range using a function number
of 101 or greater
it can be used in the way of subtotal of
1 0 9 comma b to g 2 it does not take
into account the sum function is used to
aggregate a range of cell values
regardless of whether they have any
numerical data or not
which alternately
is in contrast to a first part of the
question which states that which of the
mathematical function is smart
offset function is used with any
function expecting a reference argument
and the indirect function is employed
when you have to lock a specific cell in
a formula
see how many answered correctly
uh
i think okay
mike is now pushed to third position
there's a bit of a see-saw going on at
the top
let's see if anyone from the top five
can jump to the first three spots okay
two more questions left for that to
happen so let's move on to question
number 24
which asks which are the following
formattings in excel is considered
volatile
is it a cell formatting
is it b number formatting
is it c conditional formatting
or d
special format
uh just a reminder everyone uh if you
are one of the top three winners please
send us your screenshots to youtube
contest at the raidsimplylearn.net you
can use the screenshot of the screen
where it states the position or you can
take a picture with the phone and mail
us that picture as well this is just a
way to verify that we are indeed giving
the vouchers to the right people
and the right people have answered the
correct one which is option number c
conditional formatting it is super
volatile as they are evaluated whenever
the cell has conditional formatting and
undergoes an update
on the other hand the number formatting
and cell formatting are applied once and
they remain that way until the end of
the process of data analytics
rather simple question rather obvious
output from people
and we might see a small change in the
screen
yeah
the third position and the second
position of interchange places in the
leaderboard
giving one last option
for others to make the jump with the
last question of the day
which asks the functions below are used
to calculate the time page difference
between two dates
pick the odd one out
the options are age function
gear track function period function or
date date function
which of them i
ordered one out in this group
it's being used to calculate the time or
age difference between two
dates it's the final question a lot of
low interest this time as well
okay times up
the least number of people answered the
correct question which is age see your
prac function calculates the fraction of
the year represented by the number of
whole days between the two dates given
each date is used to help calculate the
maturity dates or due dates that fall on
the same day of the month since the date
of the issue
the dated function is also one of the
functions used to calculate the time
difference between the two dates
all the function except age are
authentic functions in excel and are
completely valid the term age was
included in the options as odd one how
to distract you from choosing the right
answer
which clearly it worked at some level
so let's see the final standings
i think it is pretty obvious that
considering only one in the top 10 was
able to answer
which makes sandeep the winner of
today's quiz congratulations sandeep uh
with mine taking the second position and
prince kumasingh as the third winner of
today's question i would request all
three of you to send the screenshots of
your screen to youtube contest at
simplylearn.net
so that you can receive your amazon
vouchers
okay in regards to everyone else i
really thank you for taking part in this
quiz and for spending this evening with
us we keep having quizzes on different
technologies so if you need to stay
updated on what we do and what the
technology is going to be the next week
or the week after that please follow us
on our social media handles and
subscribe called youtube channel
considering we advanced the quizzes a
day before
thank you so much again for spending
this time with us basically